tôt dimanche matin cet avis a été
distribué aux camionneurs garée devant
le parlement les policiers ne les tolère
rond plus encore longtemps sur le
boulevard rené lévesque
on sait combien beaucouzé
les agents sont déployées en grand
nombre prochaine étape les
contraventions juste avant de se faire
remorquer ce manifestant camionnette kit
de son plein que
la forme était policier était vraiment
gentils avec nous ont quittés conciliant
les camionneurs aussi l'ont été ils ont
attendu à 10h30 pour commencer à
klaxonner
[Musique]
mais sympathisants du mouvement ont
construit cette cabane à café c'est
notre façon de contribuer nous aussi
d'autres essayent d'amuser la foule pour
la garder plus longtemps sur place même
si la plupart des camionneurs sont
équipés pour rester leur réalité
quotidienne les rattrape on pense
peut-être partir d'aujourd'hui nous
parce que ma blonde me travail demain
moi j'entraîne la route aujourd'hui il
faut comprendre que des goûts aussi là
d'un travail à des familles ordinaires
comme tout le monde on nous demande de
manifester pacifiquement c'est ce qu'on
a fait astaro c'est un retour
d'ascenseur
les organisateurs qui veulent la levée
des mesures sanitaires promettent de
revenir pas qu'on sorte de rendez vous
tu as 2 semaines ont fait la même
affaire le batteur membres équipe leader
c'est certain certains n'ont rien à deux
semaines des jets revenir tant qu'
salaire être pas par son rôle est
d'abord demain ce piano pollue pas que
ça prouve que le monde civilisé
les manifestants disent repartir la tête
haute sans avoir dérangé les résidents
du vieux québec ni compromis l'ouverture
du carnaval
ils espèrent que leur message aura été
entendu par les élus qui ont tous choisi
sans exception de ne pas venir à leur
rencontre ici véronique prince radio
canada québec